Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. We, the most distant of peoples who dwell upon this earth, the last of the three, have been shielded until today by our very remoteness and by the obscurity in which it has shrouded our name. But now the most northerly reaches of Britain lie open to our foe, and what men know nothing about is invariably a cause of fascination. There are no peoples who dwell beyond us, nothing but waves and rocks, and the Romans who are more terrible still, for there is no escaping their exactions
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。若想每周收听独家加更节目、无广告畅听、提前解锁系列内容，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我们这片栖息于大地之极、作为人类中最后幸存者的民族，直至今日，一直因我们的偏远以及历史隐秘对我们名号的遮蔽而受到庇护。然而，如今不列颠最北端的地域向我们的敌人敞开了，而人类一无所知的事物总是不可避免地引人入胜。在我们之外再无其他民族，除了波涛、岩石，还有那些更为可怕的罗马人，因为他们强征苛税，
by submitting to them and bowing the neck. Men who have stripped the entire world bare. They have exhausted the dry land by plundering all it has to offer. So now they ransack the sea. A wealthy enemy excites their rapacity. A poor one their hunger for power. The East and West alike have failed to satisfy their appetites. Alone among men, they lust equally after the rich and the poor. What they speciously call empire is merely robbery, slaughter and looting. They create a wilderness and they call it peace. So that, Tom, was Mel Gibson in AD 83. It was, in fact, Calgacus, a British warlord who, like Mel Gibson,
哪怕你向他们臣服、低头屈膝也无路可逃。这是一群把整个世界剥得精光的人。他们通过掠夺世间一切可夺之物，榨干了这片旱地。于是，现在他们又开始搜刮海洋。富有的敌人激起他们贪婪的暴虐，贫穷的敌人则激发他们对权力的饥渴。无论是东方还是西方都无法满足他们的胃口。在这世上，唯独他们对富贵与贫贱同样充满贪欲。他们冠冕堂皇地称之为帝国，实则不过是强盗行径、屠杀与掠夺。他们制造了一片荒凉，却将其称之为和平。那么，汤姆，刚才那是公元83年的梅尔·吉布森。事实上，那是加尔加库斯，一位不列颠的军事领袖，他同梅尔·吉布森一样，
celebrated both for his breeding and for his valour. And he delivered that speech, didn't he, Calgacus, if he did deliver it, as we will discover, on a mountain called Gropius in the highlands of Scotland, or what was then called to the Romans, Caledonia. So we had Boudicca last time, and we were talking about how she was the first real great rich character in British history. And here we have the first person in all Scottish
因其门第和英勇而闻名。正如我们即将发现的那样，如果他真的发表了那番演讲的话，加尔加库斯正是在苏格兰高地一座名为格罗皮乌斯的山上（罗马人当时称之为喀里多尼亚）发表了这段演讲。所以，我们上次谈到了布迪卡，并讨论了她如何成为不列颠历史上第一位真正伟大且富有传奇色彩的人物。而在这里，我们迎来了整个苏格兰历史上第一位留下了名字的人，不是吗？是的，是的，这非常有梅尔·吉布森的感觉，因为当时的局势相当有《勇敢的心》的风范。喀里多尼亚人正驻守在名为格罗皮乌斯这座山的斜坡上，正如苏格兰后来的历史中屡次发生的那样，他们正在抵抗来自南方的庞大侵略军。
history don't we to have a name yeah yeah it was very Mel Gibson because the situation is quite Braveheart so the Caledonians are on the slopes of this mountain called Graupius and as on so many occasions in subsequent Scottish history they're resisting a vast invasion from the south. And it's been 40 years since the Romans landed in Kent, and they have now reached the highlands. And the process of conquest, as we were discussing last time in the end of our episode on Boudicca, have been devastating. So we said that in that great battle, perhaps 40,000 were slaughtered in the battle that ends her revolt. We've had genocidal campaigning in Wales, hundreds of thousands killed, hundreds of thousands enslaved. So you can see where Calgogus is coming from. And the line with which he ends that speech, they create a wilderness and they
距离罗马人登陆肯特郡已经过去40年了，而他们现在已经抵达了高地。正如我们在上一集关于布迪卡结尾时所讨论的那样，征服的过程一直是毁灭性的。当时我们提到，在那场决定她起义结局的大战中，可能有多达4万人遭到屠杀。我们在威尔士经历了灭绝种族式的战役，数十万人被杀，数十万人沦为奴隶。所以你可以理解加尔加库斯的心情。而他那篇演讲的结语——他们制造了一片荒凉，却将其
call it peace, is probably one of the most famous denunciations of imperialism of all time. I mean, it's often, often quoted, often repeated. And it seems to offer a counterpoint to the glory that was Rome. It seems to give us the view from the barbarian side, except that, of course, it's not actually verbatim. It's essentially invented by Tacitus, the great Roman historian, who is, and this is absolutely on trend with what Roman historians do. There's nothing, you know, no one would see it as being poor form. It's absolutely expected. But he is putting words into this Caledonian leader's mouth. And it appears in the biography of Agricola, who is the governor of Britain, who is leading
称之为和平——或许是有史以来对帝国主义最著名的声讨之一。我的意思是，这句话经常被引用、反复提及。它似乎为罗马曾拥有的辉煌提供了一个对立面，似乎为我们展现了来自蛮族视角的观点，当然，除了它实际上并非逐字记录的原文这一事实。它主要是由罗马伟大的历史学家塔西陀虚构出来的，而这完全符合罗马历史学者的常规做法。这并没有什么不对的，没有人会认为这是糟糕的做法。这完全是意料之中的。但他是在把自己的话塞进这位喀里多尼亚领袖的口中。这段话出现在《阿古利可拉传》中，阿古利可拉是不列颠总督，也是
the legions, say the Roman side, at the Battle of Mount Graupius. And when Tacitus gives these words to Calgacus, it's not total fantasy. He is very well informed on British affairs. Agricola was his father-in-law. He may well have served in Britain himself. So to quote Anthony Burley, who's a very distinguished expert on Northern Britain in the Roman period. And he says, why not suppose that Tacitus served in Britain in one of the four legions in the army of his father-in-law? He could well have stayed there for two to three years. And he points out that in the account of Agricola's governorship that Tacitus writes, the first three years are done in great detail. And then it becomes slightly more sketchy, implying that perhaps Tacitus was actually present in Britain.
在格罗皮乌斯山战役中率领军团（也就是罗马一方）的统帅。当塔西陀将这些话赋予加尔加库斯时，这并不是完全的幻想。他对不列颠事务非常了解。阿古利可拉是他的岳父。他本人很可能也在不列颠服过役。借用安东尼·伯利的话来说，他是罗马时期北不列颠研究领域一位非常杰出的专家。他说，为什么不假设塔西陀曾作为岳父军队中四个军团的一员在不列颠服役过呢？他很有可能在那里待了两到三年。他指出，在塔西陀所写的阿古利可拉总督任期记述中，前三年被详细记录，随后则变得有些简略，这暗示塔西陀可能确实亲历了不列颠。
So he would have had a good idea of what the Roman conquest meant for the Britons. But having said that, I think that Calchicus's speech actually tells us less about British attitudes to Roman imperialism than about Tacitus's own. And it's obvious, I mean, no man who is capable of composing that speech that you read out can possibly be reckoned to view empire and conquest as an unambiguous good. So the question then is, does this mean basically he's woke? Is he a woke historian, Roman historian, part of the woke mind virus? So we will see. We will see over the course of this episode where Tacitus is coming from.
所以他应该很清楚罗马的征服对不列颠人意味着什么。话虽如此，我认为加尔加库斯的演讲实际上与其说是反映了不列颠人对罗马帝国主义的态度，不如说是反映了塔西陀自己的态度。很明显，一个能够写出你刚才朗读的那段演讲的人，绝不可能把帝国和征服视作绝对纯粹的好事。所以问题就在于，这是否意味着他本质上是个“觉醒者”？他是一个“觉醒”的历史学家、罗马历史学家，是“觉醒思想病毒”的一部分吗？我们拭目以待。在本集的进程中，我们将一探究竟，看看塔西陀的立场究竟是什么。
Isn't that interesting? The idea that the germ of the criticism of Roman imperialism and indeed of imperialism more generally is right there at the beginning within Roman culture itself. The question is are the reasons that Tacitus is criticizing imperialism the reasons that we today might criticize imperialism and that's something that we can explore over the course of this episode. So let's get into the British context. So what is it? A generation has gone by since the arrival of the Romans in southern Britain. So that speech is AD 83. We've had Boudicca's revolt. And after that, the sheer punitiveness, the bloodthirstiness of the Roman response to that,
这难道不有趣吗？对罗马帝国主义乃至更广泛的帝国主义批评的萌芽，竟然从一开始就存在于罗马文化自身内部。问题在于，塔西陀批判帝国主义的原因，是否就是我们今天批判帝国主义的原因？这也是我们可以在本集节目中探讨的话题。那么，让我们切入不列颠的背景。情况是怎样的呢？自罗马人抵达南部不列颠以来，已经过去了一代人的时间。所以那场演讲发生在公元83年。我们经历了布迪卡的起义，而在那之后，罗马人随之展开了极其严厉、嗜血的报复，
the destruction of the great mass of people, the horde that followed Boudicca, that sends a very clear signal that the Romans are here for good. They're not going to withdraw. There was that thing that you pointed out last time, that the guy who pushed the repression was later recalled, and people felt he'd gone too far. So how did the Romans view Britain? I mean, Tacitus is not alone, I think, in feeling that the early decades of the Roman occupation
对绝大多数民众以及追随布迪卡的乌合之众的毁灭，传递出了一个非常明确的信号：罗马人是来这里长住的，他们绝不会撤退。正如你上次所指出的那样，那位推行镇压的官员后来被召回了，人们觉得他做得太过火了。那么，罗马人是如何看待不列颠的呢？我认为，塔西陀并不是唯一一个觉得罗马占领的头几十年被严重管理不善、而布迪卡的起义正是这种 mismanagement（管理不善）的表现的人。布迪卡起义的余波带来了两个结果：首先，罗马人甚至不可能再考虑撤退了。流了太多的血，投资了太多的黄金，撤退将是奇耻大辱。所以他们做好了打持久战的准备。但与此同时，我认为他们也意识到，
have been pretty badly mismanaged and that Boudicca's revolt is an expression of that. And the aftermath of Boudicca's revolt is, firstly, it's now impossible for the Romans even to contemplate withdrawal. Too much blood has been lost. Too much gold has been invested. It would be too great a humiliation. So they're in for the long haul. But at the same time, I think there is a recognition that, you know, they kind of need to up their game. The repression has gone too far.
他们确实需要提高水准了。镇压有些过头了。
There's a guilt that is a kind of an acknowledgement that Boudicca was mistreated. And there's an anxiety that Paulinus, his reprisals in the wake of the suppression of Boudicca's rebellion. I mean, he is kind of creating a desert and call it a wilderness and calling it peace. And the man who applies this perspective in the wake of Boudicca's revolt is the new procurator. So the guy who's in charge of the finances of the province. And this is a man called Gaius Julius Alpinus Classicanus. So the Alpinus points to the fact
有一种负罪感，承认布迪卡受到了虐待；同时也有人焦虑，担心保利努斯在镇压布迪卡叛乱后的报复行动。我的意思是，他某种程度上就是在制造一片荒漠，称之为荒凉，并将其命名为和平。而在布迪卡起义之后应用这种视角的人，是新任财务官，也就是负责该行省财政的人。此人名叫盖乌斯·尤利乌斯·阿尔皮努斯·克拉西卡努斯（Gaius Julius Alpinus Classicanus）。这里的“阿尔皮努斯”表明，
that he's from Southern Gaul in the region of the Alps. So maybe that Gallic background suggests why he might feel more sympathetic towards the Britons. He writes back to Rome, he writes to Nero and he says, look, this is all going too far. It's counterproductive. You need to replace Suetonius Paulinus, even though he's the great general. And so Nero sends a freedman, a man called Polykleitos, on a kind of fact-finding mission. Tacitus is very withering about the scale of the size of the mission that is sent. But it obviously does a very, very good job because it reports back and says, yes, you know, we need a new broom here. And so some ships are lost. And so they use this as an excuse to withdraw him and bring him back to Rome. And the new governor is the nephew of
他来自阿尔卑斯山地区的南高尔。或许这种高尔背景可以解释为什么他会对不列颠人表现出更多同情。他给罗马写信，给尼禄写信说：“听着，这一切都太过分了，这是适得其反的。你们需要撤换苏埃托尼乌斯·保利努斯，尽管他是个伟大的将领。”于是尼禄派了一个名叫波利克托斯的解放奴隶去执行某种实地考察任务。塔西陀对被派遣的考察团的规模大加嘲讽。但它显然完成了一项非常非常出色的工作，因为考察报告反馈说：“是的，你知道的，我们需要在这里进行一番大换血。”随后一些船只失事了，于是他们以此为借口将保利努斯撤职并召回罗马。新任总督是
Aulus Plautius, who was the original invader, the general, the head of the invasion force, the first governor of Britain. And his nephew is a man called Petronius Topilianus. And he and Classicanus work very hard, essentially, at healing the wounds, at trying to repair the damage, and they don't engage in fresh conquests. So no further wars under Topilianus' term of governorship. And Classicanus himself, already London has become the financial centre. London had been obliterated by Boudicca. Classicanus himself, already London has become the financial centre. London had been obliterated by Boudicca. Clasicanus clearly devotes himself to rebuilding it because he can recognise that it's essentially the natural place from which to administer the finances of Britain.
奥卢斯·普劳提乌斯的侄子，奥卢斯·普劳提乌斯是最初的入侵者、将领、入侵部队的最高指挥官，也是不列颠的第一任总督。他的侄子名叫佩特罗尼乌斯·图皮利亚努斯（Petronius Turpilianus）。他和克拉西卡努斯联手，基本上致力于抚平创伤、试图修复破坏，并且他们没有卷入新的征服行动。因此在图皮利亚努斯任总督期间没有发生新的战争。克拉西卡努斯本人——此时伦敦已经成为了金融中心。伦敦曾被布迪卡夷为平地。克拉西卡努斯本人——此时伦敦已经成为了金融中心。伦敦曾被布迪卡夷为平地。克拉西卡努斯显然致力于重建伦敦，因为他认识到这里本质上是管理不列颠财政的天然中心。
And when he dies in due course in 65, he's given this sumptuous funerary monument in the East End. So beyond the eastern flank of the city as the road leads out. And we know that because it was subsequently used as part of the medieval wall and found in excavations. And the original is in the British Museum, and there's a replica of it by Tower Hill Tube Station. So you can go and see that if you're passing Tower Hill Tube Station.
当他在65岁左右适时去世时，他在伦敦东区获得了一座极为豪华的葬礼纪念碑。具体位置在城市东翼外侧通往城外的道路旁。我们之所以知道这一点，是因为它后来被用作中世纪城墙的一部分，并在考古发掘中被发现。原件现存于大英博物馆，而在伦敦塔山地铁站附近则有一个它的复制品。所以如果你路过塔山地铁站，可以去参观一下。
Porto Pilianus comes to a much stickier end. So he goes back to Rome in 63 and is greeted with great honour by Nero. He's generally felt to have done a good job. And so in 68, when rebellion breaks out across the empire against Nero, Nero turns to Topilianus and puts him in charge of the defence of Italy. And Nero then commits suicide and AD 69 sees a whole host of emperors, four in total, succeeding one another. And Portopelianus gets put to death by the first of these emperors, a man called Galba. But Galba doesn't last very long. His successor Otho doesn't last very long. Then you have Vitellius and then you have Vespasian coming to power. And Vespasian,
图皮利亚努斯的结局则要棘手得多。他在63年返回罗马，受到了尼禄的隆重欢迎。人们普遍认为他干得不错。因此，在68年帝国各地爆发反对尼禄的叛乱时，尼禄转向图皮利亚努斯，让他负责意大利的防御。随后尼禄自杀，公元83年迎来了众多皇帝，总共四位，相继登台。图皮利亚努斯被这四位皇帝中的第一位、一个名叫加尔巴的人处决了。但加尔巴没有维持多久，他的继任者奥托也没有维持多久，接着是维特里乌斯，然后是韦斯帕先掌权。而韦斯帕先，
people may remember, was in command of the second legion in the original invasion back in AD 43. And he does know Britain and he kind of pacifies the empire and puts it back on its feet. But this year, AD 69, the year of the four emperors, has been turbulent for Britain. There are kind of mutinies. There are different legionary commanders backing different emperors. You get one of the legions is completely withdrawn and so what had been a garrison of four legions now consists of only three and this in turn encourages an uprising against Rome in the kingdom of the Brigantes which again we talked about before it's essentially northern what's now northern England ruled by this extraordinary
大家可能还记得，在公元43年的最初入侵中，他曾指挥第二军团。他对不列颠确实很了解，他平定了帝国并使其重回正轨。但这一年，即公元83年“四帝之年”，对不列颠来说动荡不安。这里发生了某种兵变，不同的军团指挥官支持不同的皇帝。其中一个军团被完全撤回，因此原本由四个军团组成的驻军现在只剩下三个，而这反过来又助长了不列颠国内针对罗马的起义，地点在布里甘特斯王国。正如我们之前讨论过的，这基本上是现在的英格兰北部，由这位非凡的女女王统治，
queen Carta Mand, who had been consistently pro-Roman. She was the person who had handed Caraticus over, the great, you know, original freedom fighter in Britain, to the Romans. And she has this extraordinary stronghold in North Yorkshire, a place called Stanwyck, very kind of formidable, great ramparts, four miles long in length, lots of high quality Roman goods. Cartamundua is clearly absolutely living her best life there, having a fabulous time. It's all great. But she does have problems with her erstwhile husband, who's a man called Venutius.
她就是卡塔曼杜阿（Cartimandua），她一直坚决亲罗马。她就是把不列颠伟大的原初自由斗士卡拉蒂库斯（Caratacus）交个罗马人的那个人。她在北约克郡拥有一个极其非凡的据点，一个叫斯丹维克（Stanwick）的地方。那里非常险要，有着巨大的防御工事，长达四英里，出土了大量高质量的罗马物品。卡塔曼杜阿在那里显然过着她最好的生活，过得好极了，一切都非常棒。但她确实和她昔日的丈夫——一个名叫韦努提乌斯（Venutius）的男子——有一些麻烦。
And 10 years previously, Venutius and Cartamundua had had a massive bust up. Cartamundua had kicked him out after he'd gone to war with her the romans had come to her rescue but venutius is still kind of lurking there on the margins keen to make a comeback and is all the more aggravated because cartamandua has massively sassed uh venutius by having an affair with his armor bearer a man called velicatus. Venutius is really furious and he takes full advantage of the turmoil in AD 69 to have another crack at Cartamandua to you know finish off his ex-wife. Cartamandua again appeals for help and she's rescued in the nick of time by the new governor who's been sent out by Vitellius the third of the emperors in the year of the four
10年前，韦努提乌斯和卡塔曼杜阿曾闹翻过。在韦努提乌斯对她发动战争后，卡塔曼杜阿把他赶了出去，而罗马人曾赶来救她。但韦努提乌斯仍然在边缘地带伺机而动，渴望卷土重来，并且因为卡塔曼杜阿和一个名叫韦利卡图斯（Velicatus）的侍卫私通，大大羞辱了韦努提乌斯，这让他更加恼火。韦努提乌斯极为愤怒，他充分利用了公元83年的动乱，再次试图击败卡塔曼杜阿，以此来（你知道的）彻底解决他的前妻。卡塔曼杜阿再次呼吁援助，并在千钧一发之际被新任总督救下。这位总督是四帝之年中的第三位皇帝维特里乌斯派出的，
emperors and this is a man called Vettius Balanus who is actually very very effective and he's so effective that even though Vitellius is the emperor who gets overthrown by Vespasian, Vespasian is happy to keep Balanus in post and I guess the reason for that is that he rates Balanus highly and it doesn't matter that Balanus was appointed by Vertelius because what really matters to Vespasian is that Britain is properly sorted out. So it's under Balanus that the north is pacified and he's meant to have done really well isn't he? So I read the poet Statius says he reaches Caledonian fields so is balanus the first romans traveled to scotland that's the question probably not so this is probably poetic exaggeration but probably what he is doing is sending diplomatic missions up to caledonia so
此人名叫韦蒂乌斯·巴拉努斯（Vettius Balanus），他实际上非常非常能干。他能力极强，以至于尽管维特里乌斯是被韦斯帕先推翻的皇帝，韦斯帕先依然很乐意让巴拉努斯留任。我想原因在于他高度评价巴拉努斯，而且巴拉努斯是由韦特里乌斯任命的也无所谓，对韦斯帕先来说真正重要的是不列颠得到妥善的治理。正是在巴拉努斯任内，北方被平定，人们认为他干得非常出色，不是吗？我读到诗人斯塔提乌斯（Statius）说他抵达了喀里多尼亚的原野。那么，巴拉努斯是第一个前往苏格兰的罗马人吗？这是一个问题。可能不是，这或许是诗意的夸张，但他可能做的事情是向喀里多尼亚派遣外交使团，
beyond what is now northern england into the lowlands and the aim is clearly to try and set up friendly relations with the peoples who live up there and he clearly does a good job because when he goes back in 71 Vespasian gives him patrician rank which is a very high honour indeed so he's obviously done well for himself and I think that the fact that Balanus is putting out feelers north, beyond even Brigantia, into what would now be Scotland, reflects the fact that Vespasian wants to see the whole of Britain conquered. And he feels, you know, he had served there. His son Titus, who in due course will become emperor himself, he'd served there as well. The Flavian dynasty they're called. The Flavians, I think, see it as the mission they've been given by the gods to
即超越现在的英格兰北部、进入低地地区，其明确目的是试图与生活在那里的民族建立友好关系。他显然干得不错，因为当他在71年返回时，韦斯帕先授予了他贵族身份，这无疑是极高的荣誉。所以他显然为自己建功立业了。我认为，巴拉努斯将触角向北延伸，甚至越过了布里甘特斯、进入现在的苏格兰这一事实，反映出韦斯帕先希望看到整个不列颠被征服。他觉得（你知道的）他曾在那里服过役。他的儿子提图斯——日后也将成为皇帝——也曾在那里服过役。被称为弗拉维王朝的家族，我想，弗拉维家族将征服不列颠视为神明赋予他们的使命。
conquer Britain. And there is one further person who is part of the Flavian kind of family, dynastic setup, who has been engaged in Britain. And this is our old friend Kerialis, who was the commander of the Ninth Legion that had been mauled by the Icani and the Trinovantes when he was marching to try and relieve Camulodonum. And he is the son-in-law of Vespasian. So he's married Vespasian's daughter. And when Balanus is called back, Vespasian sends Kerialis as the new governor. And you might think this is quite a weird choice, considering that he'd notoriously been defeated by the Britons. But I think Vespasian values him not just because he's obviously very loyal, because he's part of his family, but also because he's very energetic. He's very bold. He's not a man to kind of frowst around in his legionary base.
还有另一个人，他是弗拉维家族王朝体制的一部分，也曾参与过不列颠的事务，这就是我们的老朋友克里亚利斯（Cerialis）。他曾是第九军团的指挥官，当他在行军试图解救卡穆洛杜努姆时，该军团曾被艾西尼人和特里诺万特人重创。他是韦斯帕先的女婿，娶了韦斯帕先的女儿。当巴拉努斯被召回时，韦斯帕先派克里亚利斯担任新总督。你可能会觉得这是一个相当奇怪的选择，考虑到他曾因遭到不列颠人的击败而臭名昭著。但我认为，韦斯帕先重用他不仅因为他显然极其忠诚（因为他是家族成员），还因为他精力充沛、极为果敢。他不是那种在军团营地里无所事事的人。
He wants to get out there and crack on. Kerialis has proved his worth as a military man by suppressing a rebellion by the Batavians, who are those Germans who serve the Romans as auxiliaries and can swim across rivers and lakes in their armour. And they had perhaps rebelled. It's unclear exactly the degree to which they'd rebelled or they'd been embroiled in the civil war. But anyway, Kerialis had pacified Batavia and he's now come to Britain. And it's an indication of how determined Vespasian is to see Britain conquered that when Carialis comes to Britain he does so with a legion so that the strength of the island's garrison is restored from three to four so it's all go so his plan is to go up he goes by the 71 so that year that he arrives. He goes up past the Midlands.
他渴望走出去大干一场。克里亚利斯在镇压巴达维亚人叛乱的过程中证明了自己的军事价值。巴达维亚人是那些充当罗马辅助兵的日耳曼人，他们穿着铠甲就能游过河流和湖泊。他们曾发生过叛乱。目前尚不清楚他们叛乱的程度究竟有多大，或者他们是否被卷入了内战。但无论如何，克里亚利斯平定了巴达维亚，现在他来到了不列颠。这表明了韦斯帕先征服不列颠的决心有多大：当克里亚利斯来到不列颠时，他随身带了一个军团，从而将该岛的驻军兵力从三个恢复到了四个，一切都在全速推进。因此，他的计划是向北推进，他在71年——也就是他抵达的那一年——出发了。他穿过米德尔兰兹，
He goes up north of the Humber. He goes to the river Ouse. And he's heading towards the place that we would now call York. Exactly. Previously, the most northerly base was Lincoln. He now wants to push further forwards. And on the site of York, or Eberrachum, as the Romans call it, the place of yew trees, apparently it means in Britonic, is strategically a very good one because it's on the obvious route for marching northwards,
一直向北越过亨伯河，抵达乌斯河，正朝着我们今天称为约克的方向前进。没错。此前最北端的基地是林肯，现在他想要继续向北推进。而在约克（罗马人称之为埃巴拉库姆，据不列颠语意为“紫杉生长的地方”）的遗址上，从战略上讲这是一个极佳的位置，因为它位于向北行军的必经之路上，
the Great Northern Road, as it will come to be called. But it can also be supplied by sea up the Humber. And so this becomes the new base for the Ninth Legion. So it moves up from Lincoln to York. And it's obviously a launchpad for further expansion northwards. So over the term of Kerialis's governorship, there are clearly repeated battles on both sides of the Pennines, you almost on the doorstep of what today is Scotland. And in 74, Kerialis is replaced by a very, very impressive man called Frontinus, who wrote a number of works that have survived. He was clearly a very proficient engineer. So he wrote an excellent book on aqueducts, which is our main source for how aqueducts functioned. A huge inspiration to Robert Harris, Dominic, who you talked to on a bonus, didn't you? He wrote a book about Pompeii and Frotinus's book on aqueducts was a massive source for Robert Harris when he was writing that. Very concerned
也就是后来被称为“大北方路”的路线。同时它也可以通过海路经由亨伯河获得物资补给。于是，这里成为了第九军团的新基地。它从林肯移驻约克，这显然是进一步向北扩张的跳板。因此，在克里亚利斯担任总督期间，奔宁山脉两侧显然爆发了多次战斗，几乎就到了今天苏格兰的家门口。74年，克里亚利斯被一位非常非常了不起的人物弗龙蒂努斯（Frontinus）所取代。弗龙蒂努斯写过几部流传至今的著作，他显然是一位极其精通工程学的人。他写过一本关于引水渠的出色著作，这是我们了解引水渠运作方式的主要资料来源。他是罗伯特·哈里斯（Robert Harris）的巨大灵感来源，多米尼克，你曾在加更节目中采访过他，对吧？他写过一本关于庞贝古城的书，而弗龙蒂努斯关于引水渠的书是罗伯特·哈里斯写作时的一大资料来源。他非常关注
with how you repair leaks, which is one of the themes that runs throughout that novel. He's also very much a military man, so he wrote a book on military stratagems through the ages. And in doing that, he could boast a very formidable track record because he is setting out to absolutely pacify two upland areas that are on the doorsteps of the kind of the lowlands, which is Brigantia and Wales. So Brigantia pretty much has been pacified by 77, except perhaps in the Lake District, you know, Helvellyn and all that, very difficult to sort out. So, people who've been to the Lake District may have visited the Roman fort at Hardknot. That's built, you know, several decades later. It's a sign that that is the one region of Northern England that remains difficult for the Romans to pin down. And of course, Wales has been a constant source of stress for a succession of governors and frontiners. He's doing his bit. So he found two massive new legionary fortresses, one at Celeon and one at Chester. The Roman remains in those two sites
如何修复漏水问题，这是贯穿那部小说的主题之一。他也是个名副其实的军人，因此他写过一本关于历代军事谋略的书。在此过程中，他有着令人瞩目的辉煌履历，因为他着手彻底平定位于低地门口的两个高地地区，即布里甘特斯和威尔士。所以到77年为止，布里甘特斯基本上已经被平定，可能除了湖区——比如赫尔韦林山及周边那些极难处理的地方。因此，去过湖区的人可能参观过哈德克诺特的罗马堡垒。那是几十年后建造的，这表明那是英格兰北部唯一一个仍然令罗马人难以控制的地区。当然，威尔士一直是历任总督和弗龙蒂努斯不断感到压力的来源。他正在尽自己的一份力。因此他建立了两个庞大的新军团要塞，一个在卡利昂，另一个在切斯特。这两处遗址的罗马遗迹
are still very impressive to this day. More forts across Wales. And the reason why i think he's frontinus is particularly interested in seeing wales pacified is because as an engineer he's interested in all the mineral wealth that wales has to offer all the gold the silver the lead and so on and so he's absolutely determined to secure them so on this people like uh frontinus my sense had always been that britain was a complete backwater in the roman empire and basically a posting there was a it was a demotion like being sent to run one of gore hangers other
至今仍令人印象深刻。威尔士各地也建起了更多的堡垒。我认为弗龙蒂努斯之所以对平定威尔士特别感兴趣，是因为作为一名工程师，他对威尔士所能提供的所有矿产财富——所有的黄金、白银、铅等等——都感兴趣，因此他绝对决心确保这些资源的安全。对于像弗龙蒂努斯这样的人，我一直以来的感觉是，不列颠是罗马帝国的一个绝对偏远落后之地，被派往那里基本上就是一次降职，就像被派去管理高尔·汉格（Gor Hanger）的其他
podcasts tom but um but no britain is the rest is history of the uh of the roman stable is it because actually some of the people who are being sent to run Britain are absolutely tip-top people. Is that right? Well, of course, there are kind of recalcitrant and turbulent elements in the rest of history who need a whip hand to rein them in. So maybe to that extent, I think there's a sense that Britain is the most challenging province to administer. And so it's not Syria or Egypt, which really are the kind of the plum postings, because you can get rich there, basically, and it's not going to be too stressful.
播客一样，汤姆。但是，不列颠其实是罗马稳定后方的“历史的余烬”，对吗？因为实际上被派去管理不列颠的一些人都是绝对顶尖的人物。是这样吗？当然，在“历史的余烬”中，总有一些顽固和动荡的元素需要用铁腕来加以管束。因此，在某种程度上，我认为人们确实会觉得不列颠是最具挑战性、最难管理的行省。所以它不像是叙利亚或埃及，那里真的是让人垂涎的肥差，因为你在那里基本上可以发财，而且压力不会太大。
But Britain is where you send your most competent people, the guys you can trust to do a good job. And that reflects the fact that in Britain, a governor needs to be a very proficient general. There's a lot of fighting to do. But you also need to be very good as a civil administrator. So that's where Suetonius Paulinus fell down. He was a brilliant general, but he was absolutely hopeless at kind of pacifying territories that had been conquered and kind of introducing them to civilization, as the Romans would define it. By the 70s,
但在不列颠，你派去的是最有能力的人，是你可以信任能把工作做好的人。这反映出在不列颠，总督必须是一位非常精通军事的将领。这里有大量的战斗要打。但你同时还得是一位非常优秀的民政管理者。这就是苏埃托尼乌斯·保利努斯失手的地方。他是一位杰出的将领，但他完全不擅长平定已被征服的领土，也不擅长按照罗马人的定义将文明引入这些地区。到了70年代，
you have the war zone in the north. This is targeted for conquest. But by this period, the lowlands in the south are starting to recover from the depredations of the conquest and Boudicca's rebellion. This matters because you can't essentially fund the campaigns that have to be launched without extracting a bit of wealth from the lowland provinces you know you need that so that's why i think in 77 when frontinus is recalled by vespasian he sends as the new governor a man who really couldn't be better qualified for the job so this is a man called nias julius agricola we've mentioned him various points throughout this series so far. But just to give a bit more background on him, he comes from a long line of Roman citizens in southern Gaul. He'd been a student in Massilia, present day Marseille. So that was the home of Pythias. So perhaps, you know, it fostered an early interest in the northern reaches of the ocean. Very experienced in British affairs. We've already said he served under Paulinus during the Boudiccan revolt and with him in Wales. He'd commanded a legion under both Balanus and Kerialis. He'd then been given experience as a governor by Vespasian
北方的战区成了征服的目标。但在此期间，南方的低地开始从征服和布迪卡叛乱带来的破坏中恢复过来。这一点很重要，因为如果不从低地行省榨取一些财富，你就根本无法资助必须发动的战役（你知道的，你需要这些）。所以这就是为什么我认为在77年弗龙蒂努斯被韦斯帕先召回时，他派了一位再合适不过的人选担任新总督：此人名叫格奈乌斯·尤利乌斯·阿古利可拉（Gnaeus Julius Agricola）。我们在本系列节目至今的各个节点都提到过他。但为了多提供一点他的背景，他出身于南高尔的罗马公民世家，曾是马西利亚（即今天的马赛）的学生。那是皮西亚斯的故乡，所以或许（你知道的）这培养了他对海洋最北端地区的早期兴趣。他对不列颠事务经验丰富。我们已经说过，他在布迪卡起义期间曾在保利努斯手下服役，并在威尔士与他并肩作战。他曾在巴拉努斯和克里亚利斯手下指挥过军团。后来他被韦斯帕先派往高尔的阿基坦担任总督以积累治理经验。
in Aquitaine in Gaul. Essentially, he has every attribute and level of experience that Vespasian would want in a man charged with the ultimate conquest of the whole of the island and so it's Agricola who is now in a position to solve all kinds of mysteries that Pythias had hinted at that subsequent geographers had hinted at is Britain an island if it is what lies beyond Britain can the whole of the landmass be brought under Roman rule? What about Ireland, this other great island, you know, just across the sea? And it's Agricola's mission, clearly, to provide answers to all these questions. And it's a measure of how challenging this mission is, but also how effective Agricola is, he will end up serving a term as governor for
基本上，他具备了韦斯帕先对一位肩负最终征服全岛重任的人所期望的一切品质和经验水平。因此，现在轮到阿古利可拉来解开皮西亚斯曾经暗示过、后来的地理学家曾经暗示过的各种谜团了：不列颠是一座岛屿吗？如果是的话，不列颠之外是什么？整片陆地能置于罗马统治之下吗？还有爱尔兰，这另一座隔海相望的大岛呢？阿古利可拉的使命显然就是为所有这些问题提供答案。而这项使命有多么具有挑战性，同时也说明了阿古利可拉有多么高效，他最终将担任长达
seven years, which is completely unprecedented. And it witnesses seismic changes in the course of the Roman conquest of Britain. So Gnaeus Julius Agricola arrives in Britain in the year 77 and come back after the break to find out what happens next. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
七年的总督任期，这完全是史无前例的。它见证了罗马征服不列颠进程中的颠覆性巨变。格奈乌斯·尤利乌斯·阿古利可拉于公元77年抵达不列颠，我们休息之后回来，揭晓接下来会发生什么。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐界的帷幕，为你揭示这一切是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. The Britons readily submit to military service the payment of tribute and the other obligations imposed by our imperial administration,
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及提前购买现场演出门票的权限，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。不列颠人非常乐意接受兵役、缴纳贡赋以及我们帝国行政管理部门强加的其他义务，
provided that there is no abuse. This they bitterly resent, for they are broken into obedience, but not as yet to slavery. So that was Tacitus, the great Roman historian, in his biography of Agricola, the man we introduced at the end of the first half. And Tacitus wrote that in about 98, in AD 98. It's a great sort of eulogy to his father-in-law and a portrait of Agricola as the ideal Roman governor. So brilliant at the arts of war,
前提是没有任何虐待行为。对于虐待，他们深恶痛绝，因为他们已经被驯服得学会了服从，但尚未沦为奴隶。以上这段话出自罗马伟大的历史学家塔西陀在他岳父阿古利可拉的传记中的记载，阿古利可拉正是我们在上半部分结尾时介绍的那个人。塔西陀大约在公元98年写下了这本著作。这是对他岳父的一曲绝佳的颂歌，将阿古利可拉描绘成了一位理想的罗马总督。他不仅精通战争艺术，
but also the arts of kind of peace and civil administration and so on. But Tom, I see in your notes, you say it's darker and more subtle than that. A portrayal of empire itself as a kind of poison so what do you mean by that the passage that we opened this episode with the description of empire as a kind of spacious form of robbery and plunder and rape and that the romans create a wilderness and call it peace this is in the agricola tacitus is writing it and well we'll see what he means by it what his perspective on the empire is writing it. And, well, we'll see what he means by it,
同时也擅长和平与民政管理的艺术等等。但汤姆，我在你的笔记中看到，你认为这部作品比这更加黑暗、更加微妙？它将帝国本身描绘成了一种毒药。你这是什么意思？我们在本集开头引用的那段话，将帝国描述为一种体面的抢劫、掠夺和强暴形式，并称罗马人制造了一片荒凉却将其称为和平，这正是塔西陀在《阿古利可拉传》中所写的，我们将拭目以待他究竟是什么意思，他对帝国的看法是什么，
what his perspective on the empire is. But it is clear as well that he hugely admires his father in law, as well he should. You know, there is inevitably some revisionism about Agricola's record. There's surprisingly few inscriptions that bolster what Tacitus claims for him. But the evidence is clear. He's a very, very formidable figure because we do know that he does end up going very, very far north indeed. But before he launches his campaign into Caledonia, he first has to finish off the kind of the running saw that has been Wales. And because he had served with Suetonius Paulinus there, both in the kind of, the Highlands of Northern Wales and in the attack on Anglesey. You know, he has a good sense of what it would take to finish
他对帝国的看法究竟是什么。但同样显而易见的是，他极度崇拜自己的岳父，这也是他理应做到的。你知道的，关于阿古利可拉的政绩，难免存在一些历史修正主义。支持塔西陀为他所做宣称的铭文少得惊人。但证据是明确的。他是一个非常非常可怕的人物，因为我们确实知道他最终走得非常非常靠北。但在他向喀里多尼亚发动战役之前，他首先必须彻底解决威尔士这个痼疾。由于他曾与苏埃托尼乌斯·保利努斯一同在那里服役，无论是在北威尔士的高地还是在对安格尔西岛的进攻中，
this campaign off. So according to Tacitus, he attacks the Ordovicians, who are the tribal grouping in the north of Wales, directly up in their kind of their mountain fastnesses, leading his men from the front. Tacitus writes he cut to pieces almost the whole fighting force of the tribe. Having done that he then attacks Anglesey finishing off the job that Paulinus had been distracted from doing by the news of the Budokan revolt. Doesn't have boats on this occasion but does have the Batavians who strap on their armour, jump into the sea, wade across and it's curtains for all resistance on Anglesey. And it's the measure of the kind of the renown and the mystique that this ancient stronghold
（你知道的）他对结束这场战役需要付出什么有着清醒的认识。根据塔西陀的记载，他直接向北威尔士山地险要处的奥尔多维克斯人（Ordovicians）部落发起进攻，身先士卒地率领部下。塔西陀写道，他将该部落几乎所有的精锐武装力量斩尽杀绝。做完这些后，他接着进攻安格尔西岛，完成了当初保利努斯因听到布迪卡起义的消息而被迫中断的任务。这一次他没有船只，但有巴达维亚人，他们穿戴好铠甲，跳进海里，涉水渡过，安格尔西岛的所有抵抗至此宣告结束。鉴于德鲁伊的这座古老据点在罗马人心中享有崇高的声望和神秘感，
of the Druids has in Rome, that this is greeted with great enthusiasm back in the capital. And there's a kind of coin is minted showing a trousered figure from Anglesey kneeling down in the ground and accepting defeat. And this is the last mention that we get in classical texts of campaigning in Wales. So from this point, we can basically assume that Wales has been pacified. And the way that it's done is, again, it's a bit like the way that Edward I, a thousand years and more, will pacify Wales. He does it by building forts, strongholds, places that essentially can kind of act like fetters thrown across the landscape. So the gap between forts in Wales are kind of
这在首都引起了极大的热情。甚至还铸造了一种硬币，上面描绘了一个穿着裤子的安格尔西岛人跪在地上接受失败的形象。这是我们在古典文献中得到的最后一次关于威尔士战役的记载。因此，从这一点开始，我们基本可以认为威尔士已经被平定。而实现这一点的方式，再次有点类似于一千年后爱德华一世平定威尔士的方式。他是通过修建堡垒、据点来做到这一点的，这些地方本质上就像是横跨大地的枷锁。因此，威尔士堡垒之间的距离
rarely more than about 15 miles. The main corridors of movement between them are all very, very tightly controlled. To quote David Mattingly in his book, it's the first book in the New Penguin History of Britain, An Imperial Possession, brilliant book, the Roman deployment was designed in part to control the spaces between the major British peoples rather than simply occupying their heartlands. By segregating people and supervising contact between them, Rome applied the principle of divide and rule and those forts remain occupied up until about the 160s. So essentially, Agricola finishes off the job. And that means that he's all set for the north. But we said how it's important that a governor be effective as a campaigner, but he also has to heal the wounds. In the lowlands, he has to kind of fatten the sheep up ready to be fleeced and i think that
很少有超过15英里的。它们之间的主要交通走廊全都受到极其严密的控制。引用大卫·马廷利（David Mattingly）在其著作中的话——那是新企鹅版不列颠史的第一本书，名为《帝国的领地》（An Imperial Possession），一本极其出色的书——“罗马的部署部分是为了控制不列颠各大主要民族之间的空间，而不仅仅是占领他们的腹地。通过将不同人群隔离并监督他们之间的接触，罗马应用了分而治之的原则。”这些堡垒一直被驻守到公元160年代左右。因此，基本上阿古利可拉完成了这项任务。这意味着他已经完全为进军北方做好了准备。但我们说过，总督既要是一位高效的战地指挥官，同时也必须抚平创伤。在低地，他必须把羊养肥，准备随时剪羊毛。我认为
because he had lived through the buddhican revolt he is alert to the feelings of injustice that the rebels had felt and so i mean again if we can rely on tacitus and i see no reason not to he makes a point of ironing out kind of palpable injustices so Tacitus says that he never showed favouritism in his appointments. The best he was sure would best justify his trust. So he's keen to have people who are honest, people who can be trusted not to go around kind of, you know, whipping and raping leading British figures. The only question though here, Tom, is how much can we trust a book written by his son-in-law that's a deliberate hagiography of him? I think because there are no further rebellions and because Tacitus describes Agricola fostering the arts of civilization, by which he means essentially, I guess, Romanization in the
由于他曾亲历布迪卡起义，他对叛军曾感受到的不公情绪保持着警惕。所以（再次强调，如果我们能依赖塔西陀的记载，而且我看没有理由不这么做）他刻意去消除那些显而易见的不公。塔西陀说，他在任命官员时从不偏心。他深信最优秀的人才能最好地证明对他的信任。因此他热衷于起用诚实的人、可以被信任不会四处鞭笞、强暴不列颠显贵的人。不过这里唯一的问题是，汤姆，我们究竟能多大程度上信任一本由他女婿撰写、带有刻意圣徒传色彩的书呢？我认为，由于没有发生进一步的叛乱，并且由于塔西陀描述了阿古利可拉培育文明艺术的过程，他所指的基本上也就是——我想——南方低地的罗马化进程，而且考古证据支持了这一点——
southern lowlands, and the archaeological evidence backs this up so tacitus tells us that agricola encourages the elites to learn latin to wear the toga to enjoy fine dining you know this is the classic approach that the british in india will adopt encouraging leading figures in india to speak english to play cricket to buy rolls royces whateverces, whatever. And, you know, it's not coincidence because, of course, all the British administrators have read the curricula. So there is a kind of possibly a kind of direct influence there. And also what he's doing is he is encouraging the process of urbanization because the Romans need cities if they're going to make the province pay. So London is the classic example of a boom town. And with Classicarnus' sponsorship, it's already started to recover. So in AD 65,
所以塔西陀告诉我们，阿古利可拉鼓励精英阶层学习拉丁语、穿托加袍、享受精致的餐饮（你知道的，这是英国人在印度采用的经典方法，鼓励印度的领袖人物说英语、打板球、买劳斯莱斯等等）。而且，（你知道的）这并非巧合，因为所有的不列颠行政长官都读过《阿古利可拉传》，所以这里可能存在某种直接的影响。此外，他还在做的一件事是鼓励城市化进程，因为如果罗马人想让这个行省有利可图，他们就需要城市。因此伦敦就是繁荣城市的典型代表。在克拉西卡努斯的资助下，伦敦已经开始复苏。所以在公元65年，
we have the earliest known mention of its name. It appears on one of the Bloomberg tablet documents that we mentioned found in the Walbrook. But even before Agricola arrives, the forum and an amphitheatre has been constructed. And by the time that Agricola is there, it's already become the largest city in Britain. It's well on its way to becoming the imperial capital, although Camulodonum holds that position till the early second century. And its wealth is tribute to the economic benefits that Britain's integration into the empire brings. Because the combination of a kind of unitary state at peace in southern Britain, combined with access to markets on the continent, means that London is almost inevitably going to boom. It's the obvious
我们有了关于这个名字最早的已知记载。它出现在我们在沃尔布鲁克发现的彭博社木版文件之一上。但甚至在阿古利可拉抵达之前，议事广场和露天剧场就已经建成了。而当阿古利可拉到达时，它已经成为了不列颠最大的城市。它正稳步迈向帝国首都的地位，尽管卡穆洛杜努姆一直保持着该地位直到公元二世纪初。它的财富证明了不列颠融入帝国所带来的经济效益。因为南部不列颠处于和平状态的统一国家体制，加上通往欧洲大陆市场的便利条件，意味着伦敦几乎不可避免地会迎来大繁荣。它是
kind of nodal point within Britain, and docks mean that you know ships from Gaul and so on can come there so its growth is unsurprising there's one other urban centre that seems to grow organically and naturally in this period under Agricola and this is Aquae Sulis which is Bath and the reason for that is that it has the springs the hot springs and so it's a perfect place for baths. And so that grows as well. But the thing about other urban settlements in Britain is that they're pretty all artificial.
不列颠内部显而易见的节点，码头意味着来自高尔等地的船只可以抵达那里，所以它的增长并不令人意外。在这个时期，在阿古利可拉的统治下，还有另一个似乎有机且自然生长的城市中心，这就是阿夸·苏利斯（Aquae Sulis），也就是今天的巴斯。原因在于它拥有泉水、温泉，因此是建造浴场的绝佳地点。于是这座城市也随之发展起来。但关于不列颠其他城市聚落的一点是，它们几乎全都是人工建造的。
They're artificial in the way that, you know, a McDonald's in an American camp in Afghanistan is artificial. It's the kind of place that if the Romans weren't there, it wouldn't last. And that's one of the reasons why, you know, looking way ahead when roman rule collapses in britain those towns go to rack and ruin very very quickly so in other words their foundations are very shallow from the very beginning because you said looking ahead i mean
它们是人造的，就像你在阿富汗的美军营地里看到的一家麦当劳那样是人造的。这种地方要是罗马人不在那儿了，就根本维持不下去。这也是为什么，你知道的，把目光放长远来看，当罗马对不列颠的统治崩溃时，那些城镇很快就会变得破败不堪。换句话说，它们的根基从一开始就非常浅。因为你刚才说放长远来看，我的意思是
you're looking three centuries ahead or whatever in all that time they don't really put down enough deep enough roots to survive once the colonial power is gone no and that's why you know again tacitus is bigging up agricola but i'm sure it's not just agricola all the governors are doing it but tacitus says of agricola he gave private encouragement and official assistance to the building of temples public squares and good houses because it wouldn't happen without roman encouragement we've not talked at all about how many Romans actually are in Britain. People don't move to Britain voluntarily, presumably, in great numbers. I think they do if they're merchants, if they're suppliers. Of course, the military, we saw lots of veterans settling at Camlidonum. That didn't work out well. But veterans continue to do that. But people aren't
你把目光投向了三百年后，或者诸如此类的时间，而在那么长的时间里，一旦殖民势力消失，它们其实并没有扎下足够深、足以生存的根基。没有，这就是为什么，还是那句话，塔西佗在大肆赞美阿格里科拉，但我敢肯定不仅是阿格里科拉，所有的总督都在这么做。不过塔西佗关于阿格里科拉提到，他给予建造神庙、公共广场和优秀房屋以个人的鼓励和官方的协助，因为如果没有罗马的鼓励，这些是不会发生的。我们之前完全没有讨论过，到底有多少罗马人真正身处不列颠。人们大概不会成群结队地自愿搬到不列颠去吧。我想如果是商人或供应商的话，他们是会去的。当然还有军队，我们看到很多退伍老兵在卡姆洛杜纳姆定居。那结果并不好。但退伍老兵们依然在这样做。不过人们并不是
generally sitting there in Spain or southern France or somewhere and saying, I'd like to move to Britain. No, they're not. Because what's there for you? Britain remains despised by the Romans, certainly the Roman ruling classes, right up to the end. So even in the late fourth century, you have poets in Gaul who just find it hilarious, the idea that you might have a poet in Britain, like Cicero had been. I mean, nothing has really changed. And I think the sense of Britain as a frontier state, it endures. Yeah, so there's a guy called Stuart Laycock, who wrote a book called Britannia, Failed State, and then another book on Roman Britain, in which he essentially argues that the tribal groupings persist in a much stronger way than
通常坐在西班牙、法国南部或某个地方然后说：“我想搬到不列颠去。”不，他们才不呢。因为那儿有什么等着你？不列颠一直被罗马人所鄙视，尤其是罗马统治阶层，直到最后都是如此。所以即使在公元四世纪末，高卢的诗人们仍然觉得，不列颠竟然也会有像西塞罗那样的人当诗人，这个想法简直滑稽透顶。我的意思是，一切其实都没有改变。而且我认为，不列颠作为一个边境省份的这种观念一直在延续。对，所以有个叫斯图尔特·莱科克的人，他写了一本名为《不列颠尼亚：失败的国家》的书，随后又写了一本关于罗马不列颠的书。他在书中基本主张：部落集团的存在比
people have thought, and that the foundations of Roman rule are incredibly shallow. But equally, Britain will always be heavily garrisoned. And so that means that as long as there are successful armies there, there are opportunities for a kind of simulacrum of classical Mediterranean civilization to be planted there. And that matters because, you know, just to reiterate, you need these urban centers if you are going to have a proper taxation system. And taxation system is crucial to the successful functioning of the province. And you can't have a taxation system, in the Roman opinion, without a census. So we know that from, you know, from the New Testament. It's why the story of the Holy Family going to Bethlehem is kind of faintly credible. And wherever the Romans go, they hold a census.
人们想象的要强大得多，而且罗马统治的根基极其薄弱。但同样地，不列颠也总是驻扎着重兵。这意味着，只要那里有成功的军队，就会有机会把某种古典地中海文明的模拟品植入到那里。这很重要，因为，你知道的，再重申一遍，如果你想建立一个完善的税收系统，你就需要这些城市中心。而税收系统对于该省份的成功运转至关重要。而且在罗马人看来，没有人口普查，你就无法建立税收系统。我们从新约圣经里也知道这一点。这就是为什么圣家族去伯利恒的故事多少显得有点可信。并且罗马人无论走到哪里，都要进行人口普查。
Agricola, we're told by Tacitus, does this. Records are compiled, stored in London, which has already become the financial capital. And, you know, by the standards of a pre-modern system, this is amazing. I mean, it's a very, very sophisticated framework for extorting money out of conquered peoples and provides a kind of template for subsequent imperial systems. And it establishes a template as well for a curricular's terms of office. So in the winter, he operates on building baths or holding censuses and sorting out tax. And the summer, he goes off to war. So this is the great project for which he's best known.
塔西佗告诉我们，阿格里科拉就是这么做的。各种记录被汇编并存放在伦敦——伦敦此时已经成为了金融中心。你知道的，以一个前现代系统的标准来看，这太惊人了。我的意思是，这是一个非常非常成熟的框架，用于从被征服的人民身上搜刮钱财，并为后来的帝国系统提供了一种模板。它也为阿格里科拉的任期确立了一种模式。所以在冬天，他致力于修建浴场、进行人口普查和整顿税收。到了夏天，他就去打仗。所以这就是他最著名的伟大宏图。
The mission that Vespasian has given him, which is the conquest of Caledonia. As you said, the Flavian dynasty see this as their mission from the gods. Of course, Vespasian dies in 79. He's succeeded by his son Titus. And Titus is a little bit little bit like I guess any new emperor a bit like Claudius right at the beginning of this story he needs the boost of conquest to give him legitimacy and so that presumably lies behind Agricola's enterprise it does and by 80 so that's the second year of Titus's rule when he inaugurates the coliseum back in rome
韦帕芗交托给他的使命，就是征服卡列多尼亚。正如你所说，弗拉维王朝将此视为神明赋予他们的使命。当然，韦帕芗在公元79年去世了。他的儿子提圖斯继位。提图斯有点像——我猜任何新皇帝都有点像，就像这个故事一开始的克劳迪乌斯一样——他需要征服带来的声望来赋予其合法性，所以这大概就是阿格里科拉采取行动的背后原因。确实如此，到了公元80年——也就是提图斯统治的第二年，当他在罗马重新启用斗兽场时
one of the beasts that is featured in the inaugural games is a bear from caledonia there's a criminal who's kind of crucified and the bear is encouraged to devour his intestines and this is seen as all very exciting and the fact that you have a bear from Caledonia imprisoned within the arena symbolically is an illustration to the Roman people that not just the beasts but the land and the peoples that live on the land have now been subordinated and this is seen as an amazing feat because to Roman geographers Caledonia is the epitome of barbarism they describe it as being one continual forest, which of course it isn't. But by casting it as a forest, they're essentially saying, you know,
在落成典礼上亮相的野兽之一，就是一只来自卡列多尼亚的熊。有个罪犯被钉在十字架上，然后那只熊被引诱去吞食他的内脏，这被认为是非常激动人心的事。一只来自卡列多尼亚的熊被禁锢在竞技场内，这一事实象征性地向罗马人民表明，不仅是野兽，连这片土地以及生活在这片土地上的人民现在都已经臣服了。这被视为一项了不起的壮举，因为对罗马的地理学家来说，卡列多尼亚是野蛮的化身。他们将其描述为一片连绵不断的森林，当然实际并非如此。但通过将其描绘成森林，他们基本上是在说，
it is absolutely the pits. They completely take for granted that its inhabitants are beyond savage. You know, these are barbarians who are even larger boned than the Britons in the South. They're orange haired. Pompononius mailer who's a geographer writing back in the time of claudius he describes the inhabitants of caledonia as being uncouth more ignorant of what makes for civilization than people anywhere in the world almost wholly lacking in respect for the gods and the literal meaning of caledonia seems to be hard men hard land yeah made in scotland from girders that kind of image and the orange hair they pick up on the orange hair so so early on they do so by 81 which is four years into his term of office agricola has secured a frontier that is spanning the clyde and
这地方简直糟透了。他们理所当然地认为这里的居民野蛮到了极点。你知道的，这些野蛮人的骨骼甚至比南方的不列颠人还要大。他们长着橙红色的头发。庞波尼乌斯·梅拉是一名在克劳迪乌斯时代写作的地理学家，他将卡列多尼亚的居民描述为粗野、比世界上任何地方的人都更无知于文明的要素、几乎完全不懂得对神明保持敬畏。而“卡列多尼亚”的字面意思似乎就是硬汉、贫瘠的土地。对，苏格兰人用横梁制造的那种形象。还有橙红色的头发，他们很早就注意到了橙红色的头发。所以到了公元81年——也就是他任职的第四年，阿格里科拉已经巩固了一条跨越克莱德湾和
the fourth so that's basically between edinburgh and. It's where the Antonine Wall will run in due course. And from here, he's in a position to scope out, you know, Caledonia to the north, the Highlands, but also Ireland, you know, which isn't far, kind of within, you know, you can see it from the southern tip of Scotland. And Ireland in Agricola's time is to Britain what Britain was to Gaul back in Julius Caesar's time so you know as in Caesar's time merchants going to Britain can report back to the imperial authorities in Gaul so you have merchants Roman merchants going to Ireland and reporting back to Agricola and Agricola has established treaties of friendship with various Irish leaders. You have an Irish king who's been thrown out, who takes refuge with Agricola, asks him to intervene. So this is very, very familiar from both the time of Julius Caesar
福斯湾的边境。这基本上就是日后安东尼长城所处的位置。从这里开始，他有能力去勘测北部的卡列多尼亚、高地，还有爱尔兰。爱尔兰离得不远，某种程度上，你从苏格兰的最南端就能望见它。在阿格里科拉的时代，爱尔兰对于不列颠而言，就像当年尤利乌斯·恺撒时代的不列颠对于高卢一样。所以就像恺撒时代去不列颠的商人可以向高卢的帝国当局报告一样，罗马商人也会去爱尔兰并向阿格里科拉汇报。阿格里科拉与多位爱尔兰首领建立了友好条约。有一个被驱逐的爱尔兰国王，他向阿格里科拉寻求庇护，并请求他进行干预。这与尤利乌斯·恺撒
and Claudius. These are all the opportunities that the Romans need to launch an invasion. And in fact, according to Tacitus, Agricola was very tempted. So Tacitus writes, I've often heard Agricola say that Ireland could be reduced and held by a single legion with a fair-sized force of auxiliaries and that it would be easier to hold Britain
和克劳迪乌斯的时代非常非常相似。这些都是罗马人发动入侵所需要的契机。事实上，根据塔西佗的记载，阿格里科拉非常心动。因此塔西佗写道：我经常听到阿格里科拉说，只需一个军团加上一支规模可观的辅助部队，就能征服并控制爱尔兰；如果能将不列颠
if it were completely surrounded by Roman armies so that liberty was banished from its sight. Fortunately for the Irish, Agricola decides he doesn't have time because his focus is Caledonia. That's what Titus back in Rome wants him to do. And so Ireland is left alone. And in 81, when Titus dies and is succeeded by his brother Domitian, and Domitian, unlike Titus, has not served in Britain, in fact, hasn't served in a military context anywhere, he has even more reason to want great military glory that he can trumpet. And so this means that essentially
完全被罗马军队包围，使其视野中不见自由的踪影，那么控制不列颠就会容易得多。幸运的是对于爱尔兰人来说，阿格里科拉觉得自己没有时间，因为他的重心是卡列多尼亚。那是远在罗马的提图斯希望他去完成的事。于是爱尔兰被放过了。到了公元81年，提图斯去世，他的兄弟图密善继位。图密善与提图斯不同，他没有在不列颠服役过，事实上，他根本没有在任何地方的军事领域服役过。因此他更有理由渴望获得能够大肆宣扬的伟大军事荣耀。这意味着基本上
Agricola has been told, get on with it. I want all of Britain conquered. And so this is what Agricola sets out to do. And he pursues a two-pronged strategy by land and by sea. So by land, advancing along the kind of the lowland strip on the eastern flank of Scotland. So leaving the highlands, you know, the mountainous regions well alone. He doesn't even attempt to go into them. And he reaches almost all the way up to the Murray Forth. So up to Culloden of course what's he find as in obviously there's so much we can't know because there aren't really many
阿格里科拉接到了命令：“放手去干吧。我想要整个不列颠都被征服。”于是这就是阿格里科拉着手去做的事情。他采取了水陆并进的双管齐下的战略。在陆地上，沿着苏格兰东翼的低地狭长地带推进。因此，高地和那些山脉地区被完好地避开了，他甚至没有试图进入其中。他几乎一直推进到了默里湾。也就是一直打到了卡洛登。当然，他发现了什么呢？显然，由于除了塔西佗之外没有多少
written sources other than tacitus but is our sense that what he finds in what's now scotland is pretty similar to what he finds in wales or northern england i.e the village settlements people painted blue all that kind of stuff or is it very different? Let me read you what Ronald Hutton in his book Pagan Britain has to say on this. So this is a description of Britain in the late Iron Age just before the Roman invasion and he says it's the southeast itself you know very Romanized imported Roman or Roman style goods then northern and west of this area so the midlands yorkshire so on a zone that had smaller settlements and farmsteads numerous enclosures and a greater emphasis on
文字记载，我们有太多事情无从得知，但我们的直觉是，他在如今的苏格兰发现的情况，跟他在威尔士或英格兰北部发现的很相似吗？比如村庄聚落、浑身涂成蓝色的人，所有这些？还是说有很大不同？让我读读罗纳德·赫顿在他的书《异教不列颠》中对此的看法。这是一对晚期铁器时代不列颠的描述，就在罗马入侵之前。他说，东南部本身非常罗马化，引进了罗马或罗马风格的商品；然后在这个区域的北部和西部，比如米德兰兹、约克郡等等，是一个拥有较小聚落和农庄、众多宅地围场，并且更加侧重于
pastoral farming the rest of the island so that would include wales and it would certainly include caledonia exhibited much more continuity with the earlier iron age lacking coins lacking continental manufacturers and indeed large central places of assembly so political units like when a greeker gets into caledonia are there tribal strongholds are there warlords no it's kind of homesteads fortified enclosures on a much much kind of smaller scale so therefore on one level kind of easier to conquer i suppose but on another kind of impossible because you can't pin them down. There's no central authority. No capital, no king, nothing you can capture to end the war. Yes. And you can be kind of lulled by this, I suppose, into thinking that, you know,
畜牧业的地区。岛屿的其余部分——这肯定包括威尔士，也绝对包括卡列多尼亚——与早期铁器时代表现出更多的连续性，缺乏硬币、缺乏来自欧洲大陆的制成品，也缺乏大型的中央集聚场所。所以，当阿格里科拉进入卡列多尼亚时，政治单位是怎样的？有没有部落据点？有没有军阀？没有，这更像是宅地，是规模小得多的 fortified enclosures（防御性围场）。所以从某种程度上讲，我猜可能更容易征服，但从另一方面讲又是不可能的，因为你无法锁定他们。没有中央集权。没有首都，没有国王，没有什么可以靠攻占来结束战争。是的。你可以对此掉以轻心，我猜，以为
the Caledonians are like midges. They're kind of annoying, but they can't ultimately do you that much damage except of course there is always the risk that if you go crashing up there with your legions it will encourage people who previously had been isolated and disparate to gather together to try and form a kind of guerrilla army that can then attack the invaders. And this is actually what happens in 82. So this is the sixth year of Agricola's term of office as governor, that the Caledonians launch a night attack against the hapless Ninth Legion, who are always regularly being mauled.
卡列多尼亚人就像蠓虫一样。他们有点烦人，但最终对你造成不了太大伤害——当然，除非一直存在这样一种风险：如果你带着军团气势汹汹地冲上去，这会激那些原本孤立和分散的人聚集起来，试图组成某种游击军队来攻击入侵者。这其实就是公元82年发生的事情。当时是阿格里科拉担任总督的第六年，卡列多尼亚人对倒霉的第九军团发动了一次夜袭——这个军团总是定期遭到重创。
And the Ninth Legion is taken by surprise. Their camp might almost have been overrun, except that Agricola is able to come and reinforce them. And Agricola turns it to his own ends by saying, well, you know, you've been given a bloody nose. We've got to get on and get revenge for that. And the 9th and all the other legions go cheer and say, yeah, let's go there. Let's get to the ends of the world. And according to Tacitus, this is how Agricola gets his men to share in the dream of conquering the whole of Britain. So, you know, it's a challenge. There's no question about it. But Agricola has his instructions. And so the building of infrastructure, roads, forts, it's worked in Wales. There's no obvious reason why it wouldn't work in Scotland. And there's
第九军团被打了个措手不及。他们的营地差点就被攻破了，幸亏阿格里科拉能够及时赶来增援他们。阿格里科拉顺势转为利用这一点，说道：“好吧，你们挨了记闷棍。我们必须继续前进，去报仇雪恨。”第九军团和所有其他军团都欢呼雀跃，说：“好啊，我们去吧。让我们去世界的尽头。”根据塔西佗的说法，阿格里科拉就是这样让他的士兵们共同拥有征服整个不列颠的梦想的。所以，这是一个挑战，毫无疑问。但阿格里科拉有他的指令。因此，基础设施、道路、堡垒的建设在威尔士取得了成功。没有明显的理由说明它在苏格兰不能成功。而且还有
also an additional factor, which is that Agricola has got a fleet. And this is central to his whole plan, because it means that his army can be supplied by sea. And also that the fleet can be used to kind of ferry small groups of soldiers up and down to wherever they're needed. So if there's a stronghold, you know, on an isolated promontory or something like that, the soldiers can be taken there. Of course, for the Romans who were essentially used to much calmer seas the North Sea off the Scottish coast can be very very frightening and Tacitus describes how soldiers and the sailors when they meet up they kind of compete by saying you know which is more dangerous the Caledonians or the breakers and the rocks of the sea and Tacitus also reports that the Britons themselves so the people in Caledonia are much
一个附加因素，那就是阿格里科拉拥有一支舰队。这是他整个计划的核心，因为这意味着他的军队可以通过海路获得补给。而且这支舰队还可以用来将小股士兵通过水路运送到任何需要他们的地方。所以，如果某个孤立的海角或其他地方有一个据点，士兵们就可以被运送到那里。当然，对于习惯了更加平静的海面的罗马人来说，苏格兰海岸外的北海可能会非常非常可怕。塔西佗描述了士兵和水手们碰面时，他们会如何争论不休，比试着说是卡列多尼亚人更危险，还是汹涌的海浪和海中的岩石更危险。塔西佗还报道说，不列颠人自己——也就是卡列多尼亚当地人——对舰队的恐惧远远大于对陆军的恐惧。
more intimidated by the fleet than they are by the army so he writes the Britons for their part we learned from prisoners were dismayed by the appearance of the fleet now that the places of their sea were opened up they felt that their last refuge in defeat was closed against them them so by 88 agricola is ready for he hopes will be the final push by both land and sea so shall i read you what i wrote i think everybody would really love that i think they would so repeatedly confronted by roman steel the caledonians had melted away into bogs and woods as insubstantial so it seemed to the frustrated invaders as the cloud that veiled the highland peaks but now at last they were brought to battle and this dominic is mount graupius don't know where it is exactly but probably in the vicinity of aberdeen perhaps
因此他写道：据我们从俘虏那里得知，不列颠人对舰队的出现感到惊恐万状；现在他们海上的隐秘之处被打开了，他们感到自己战败后的最后退路也被切断了。所以到了公元88年，阿格里科拉为他所希望的水陆联合最终进攻做好了准备。那我该读读我写的东西吗？我想每个人都会非常喜欢的。我想他们会的。面对罗马的钢铁长剑，卡列多尼亚人一次次消融在沼泽和树林中，在备受挫折的侵略者眼中，他们就像笼罩在高地山峰上的云雾一般虚无缥缈。但现在，他们终于被逼迎战了——而多米尼克，这就是格鲁庇乌斯山之战。我不知道它具体在哪里，但可能在阿伯丁附近
and this is where calgarcus supposedly gives his great talk. Did he even exist? Don't know. I mean, there is a theory that the name is derived from the armour, the sword man, the armour keeper, Venutius, the Brigantian chief. So that's, I don't know, who knows. But what we do know is that at last Agricola has managed to encourage the Caledonians to form a kind of coherent army with chariots and everything and he's done this essentially by kind of raiding the length of the coastline so that the Caledonians feel they've got no choice but to try and see the invader off in pitch battle and they assemble on the foothills of Mount Graupius there's lots of
而传说加尔古斯正是在这里发表了他那篇伟大的演讲。他真的存在吗？不知道。不过有一种理论认为，这个名字源于盔甲、剑客、军械库看守人，就像布里甘特人的首领韦努提乌斯那样。所以这，谁知道呢。但我们所知道的是，阿格里科拉终于设法激起了卡列多尼亚人组成一支拥有战车和一切的连贯军队的斗志。他基本上是通过沿着整个海岸线进行突袭来做到这一点的，这使得卡列多尼亚人觉得他们别无选择，只能在阵地战中试着击退入侵者。他们聚集在格鲁庇乌斯山的丘陵地带，那里有许多
yelling chanting cheering kind of shenanigans with chariots zipping up and down. And then the next day, the battle is joined and it's actually the Batavians, you know, these German auxiliaries who've been a feature of the conquest right from the very beginning, who take the lead against the enemy. And then it's the cavalry that finished them off after the legions have essentially kind of cut them to pieces and the next day at dawn agricola sends horsemen out to reconnoiter the vicinity to see if there's any fighting that needs to be done there isn't so tacitus writes in kind of chilling terms the silence of desolation reigned on all sides the hills were abandoned distant homesteads put to the torch not a soul was to be seen by our scouts. And the estimate of casualties about 10,000. I mean, a real massacre again. And so Agricola assumes this is it. This is
叫喊声、歌唱声、欢呼声，还有战车在上下驰骋的各种恶作剧般的举动。到了第二天，战斗打响了。实际上是巴达维人——这些自最初起就一直是征服行动特点的日耳曼辅助部队——带头冲向敌人。接着，在军团基本上将敌人切成碎片之后，骑兵完成了最后的收割。第二天黎明，阿格里科拉派骑兵出去侦察周边地区，看看是否还有需要战斗的地方。并没有。于是塔西佗用令人毛骨悚然的词句写道：四周弥漫着荒凉的死寂。山丘被废弃，远处的农舍被付之一炬，我们的侦察兵看不到一个身影。估计伤亡人数约为一万人。我的意思是，这又是一次真正的屠杀。所以阿格里科拉认为就是这样了。这就是
the great battle he's been looking for. He takes hostages. He goes back south for the winter, but he leaves his men in situ north of the Firth of Forth for the first time. They are commissioned to build more forts, to construct more roads, to absolutely nail down the occupation. And at the foot of a glen beside the River Tay, a place that's now called Inchtut Hill, they build the most northerly legionary base ever constructed, you know, so large enough to host 5,000 men. There's nothing really there to see now except for ridges because it's all covered over in grass but it is actually the best preserved legionary fortress anywhere to be seen in the Roman Empire. It's an amazing place to go and wander around. You really feel the kind of the ghosts there. It's built to be the headquarters of a permanent occupation force
他一直在寻找的那场伟大之战。他扣押了人质，在冬天来临前撤回南方，但有史以来第一次将他的部下留在了福斯湾以北的阵地上。他们的任务是建造更多的堡垒、修建更多的道路，彻底巩固占领。在泰河边的一个峡谷底部，一个现在被称为因奇图希尔（Inchtut Hill）的地方，他们建造了罗马帝国有史以来最北端的军团基地，其规模足以容纳五千人。现在那里除了草地覆盖下的山脊之外，几乎没什么可看的了，但它实际上是罗马帝国境内保存最完好的军团要塞。那是一个令人惊叹的地方，值得去四处走走。你真的能感觉到那里的幽灵。它被建造为一支永久占领军的总部
so an amazing place. Meanwhile by sea the roman fleet is heading northwards and the aim is to demonstrate that britain is indeed an island so there's a sense you've conquered the land now you conquer the ocean which has always been seen by the romans as a dimension of the supernatural but now agricola is all out so they head north of sc Scotland. They see Orkney. They land there. They subdue it. They even glimpse Shetland, which Agricola said, don't go and attack that. In his reports back, he says, we have glimpsed Thule, Ultima Thule. You know, I mean, amazing. They then complete their circumnavigation of Caledonia and they demonstrate that Britain is indeed an island. And back in Rome, you know, this is kind of space race stuff again. This is
所以这是一个神奇的地方。与此同时，在海上，罗马舰队正向北进发，目的是证明不列颠确实是一个岛屿——所以有一种感觉：你征服了陆地，现在你征服了海洋。海洋在罗马人看来一直是超自然现象的一个维度，但现在阿格里科拉全力以赴了。因此他们驶向苏格兰以北。他们看到了奥克尼群岛。他们登陆并在那里取得了胜利。他们甚至隐约看到了设得兰群岛，阿格里科拉当时说：“不要去攻击那个。”他在回传的报告中说：“我们瞥见了图勒，极北的图勒。”你知道的，太惊人了。随后他们完成了对卡列多尼亚的环航，并证明了不列颠确实是一个岛屿。而在罗马，你知道的，这又是太空竞赛级别的事情了。这是
moon landing stuff. It's greeted with even more enthusiasm than the news of the victory at Mons Grappius. And poets are all over it. The furthest limits of the world have surrendered around which the ebbing flood tide roars. Great stuff. Well, they're not wrong. I mean, these are people whose frontier is on the euphrates or in the sahara to go as far as they've gone northwards is an extraordinary feat yeah so agricola it can now write to domitian and say you know mission completed the entire island is now peaceful it's now secure it's now conquered and so domitian takes him at his word and calls him back and Grickley goes back to Rome he's given signal honours he's given a statue in the Forum of Augustus where all
登月级别的事情。人们对它的热情甚至超过了格鲁庇乌斯山大捷的消息。诗人们对此赞不绝口：“世界的尽头已经臣服，退潮的海水在其周围咆哮。”太棒了。好吧，他们没有错。我的意思是，这些人的边境原本在幼发拉底河或撒哈拉沙漠，能一路向北走到他们所到达的地方，这是一项非凡的壮举。是的，所以阿格里科拉现在可以写信给图密善说：“任务完成了，整个岛屿现在都是和平的、安全的、被征服了的。”于是图密善信以为真，把他召回了。阿格里科拉回到罗马，被授予了显赫的荣誉，在奥古斯都广场拥有了一座雕像，那里的
the statues are of the greatest heroes from the city's history so I mean this is an amazing honour and in Britain itself the completion of the conquest of the island is commemorated by the construction of an enormous four-sided triumphal arch at Richborough which is where Aulus Plautius and his legions had originally landed and is still seen as the kind of the gateway to Britain so rather like the gateway of India in Bombay again the British are conscious of this as kind of a precedent. And Virgil, who'd written Empire Without Limits, Imperium Sine Fine, you know, it's looked like this is true. It's happened. The Romans have done it. But I said that Inchtoot Hill, this great legionary fortress, is the best preserved. And that's because it only lasts for three years. And so it's then abandoned. And it's like a kind of ghost town. And the reason
雕像全都是城市历史上的伟大英雄。所以我的意思是，这是一个极高的荣誉。而在不列颠本土，对这个岛屿征服的完成是通过在里奇伯勒（Richborough）建造一座巨大的四面凯旋门来纪念的——里奇伯勒正是奥卢斯·普劳提乌斯和他的军团最初登陆的地方，并且一直被视为通往不列颠的大门。这很像孟买的印度门，英国人再次将此视为一种先例。维吉尔曾写过“无疆之帝国”（Imperium Sine Fine），现在看起来确实如此了。事情就这样发生了。罗马人做到了。但我说过因奇图希尔这座伟大的军团要塞保存得最好，那是因为它只存在了三年就被废弃了。它就像一座鬼城。原因
for this is that there is a massive crisis in the Balkans. People called the Dacians, who are a very menacing military presence beyond the Danube, have crossed into the Balkans. Domitian needs to staunch this gap in the frontier. So he summons one of the four legions from Britain. Caledonia, you know, is a great trophy, but it's not as important as preserving the Roman presence in the Balkans. That might be fatal to the entire fabric of the empire. And so Caledonia, the whole of Caledonia is abandoned. And if you go to the National Museum of Scotland, there's this incredible kind of tangle of metal nails that the Romans buried to ensure that the locals wouldn't be able to get hold of it and melt it down and turn it into swords or spearheads or whatever. I mean, it's really amazing. Massive tribute to the scale of the occupation.
是巴尔干地区发生了巨大的危机。被称为达西亚人的一群人在多瑙河彼岸构成了极具威胁的军事力量，他们已经跨入了巴尔干。图密善需要堵住边境上的这个缺口。于是他召回了驻扎在不列颠的四个军团之一。卡列多尼亚，你知道的，是一个巨大的战利品，但它不如维护罗马在巴尔干的存在重要。那可能会对帝国的整个基业造成致命打击。因此，卡列多尼亚，整个卡列多尼亚都被放弃了。如果你去苏格兰国家博物馆，那里有不可思议的一大团金属钉子，是罗马人埋藏起来的，以确保当地人无法弄到它们并将其熔化改造成剑、矛尖或其他东西。我的意思是，这真的很惊人。这是对占领规模的巨大印证。
And also, I'm sure, you know, the sense of disappointment that everybody who'd been involved in the conquest of Caledonia must have felt. So Tacitus is, you know, I mean, he's absolutely merciless about this. He laments that Britain had no sooner been conquered than it had immediately been given up. He blames Domitian for this. He says that Domitian is jealous of Agricola. You know, he'd rather abandon Caledonia than allow Agricola to enjoy his glory. This is incredibly unfair. Just because strategically, what is in Caledonia that would make you want to commit? I mean, I don't want to offend our Scottish listeners,
而且我也确信，所有参与征服卡列多尼亚的人心中一定都充满了失望感。所以塔西佗，你知道的，他对此可以说是毫不留情。他哀叹不列颠才刚被征服就立刻被放弃了。他为此责怪图密善。他说图密善嫉妒阿格里科拉。你知道的，他宁愿放弃卡列多尼亚，也不愿让阿格里科拉独享荣耀。这极其不公。仅仅从战略上讲，卡列多尼亚有什么东西能让你想要去投入？我的意思是，我不想冒犯我们的苏格兰听众，
but what is there in the first century AD that would mean you would want to commit so many military and financial resources when you have such pressing problems on the Danubian frontier or something which is much more important to you? I mean, Domitian took the only possible decision, didn't he? Tacitus is a great hater. And of course, Dominic, as a historian yourself, that's not something that you would ever surrender to. I mean, you love everybody. But Tacitus really hates Domitian and always thinking the worst of him and entirely interprets the withdrawal from caledonia
但在公元一世纪，有什么东西能让你愿意投入如此多的军事和财政资源呢？当你面对多瑙河边境上那样紧迫的问题、或者对你来说重要得多事情的时候？我的意思是，图密善做出了唯一可能的决定，不是吗？塔西佗是个擅长痛恨的人。当然，多米尼克，作为一个历史学家，你绝不会屈服于这种情绪。我的意思是，你爱每一个人。但塔西佗真的很讨厌图密善，总是把对方想得很坏，并且完全
through the prism of domitian's personal envy of agricola but he also interprets it in another way and this comes to how tacitus understands the roman conquest of britain and more generally the whole project of roman imperialism because as well as blaming Domitian for the abandonment of Caledonia, he also blamed something profounder, which is his notion that the Romans themselves have been sapped by their very greatness, that they've become soft, that they've become flabby. And this is why he gives this speech to Calgarcus. It's why he admires the Caledonians, actually for the same reason that most Romans despise them, for their very lack of civilization, because this has prevented them from going soft. You know, they remain hard men.
通过图密善对阿格里科拉的个人嫉妒这一棱镜来解读对卡列多尼亚的撤军。但他也从另一个角度进行了解读，这就回到了塔西佗如何理解罗马对不列颠的征服，以及更广泛地如何理解罗马帝国主义的整个宏伟计划。因为除了指责图密善放弃卡列多尼亚之外，他还指责了更深层的东西——即他的一种观点，即罗马人本身已经被他们的伟大所削弱，他们变得软弱了，变得臃肿了。这就是为什么他让加尔古斯发表了那番演讲。这也是为什么他钦佩卡列多尼亚人，实际上原因与大多数罗马人鄙视他们的一样——正是因为他们缺乏文明，因为这使他们免于变软弱。你知道的，他们依然是硬汉。
That's what Caledonians are. And this reminds Tacitus very clearly of the traditional Roman values that he is a huge admirer of and which he feels have been lost. And when he describes how Tacitus sponsors the civilizing of the Britons down in the lowlands, he sees this as essentially being the same process of corruption that has affected the romans in the capital and across the heartlands of the empire so the dissipating effects of luxury tom yeah and so again there's a very very famous passage where he describes this you know the process of wearing togas and having central heating and all that so he writes so the population was gradually led into the demoralizing temptations of arcades baths and sumptuous banquets the unsuspecting britain spoke of such novelties as civilization when in fact they were only a feature of their enslavement and this essentially is the wilderness
卡列多尼亚人就是这样。这让塔西佗非常清晰地想起了他极力推崇并认为已经失落的传统罗马价值观。而当他在描述塔西佗如何资助低地不列颠人走向文明时，他认为这本质上与影响了首都和帝国腹地罗马人的腐化过程是同一回事。也就是说，是奢靡带来的消解作用，汤姆。所以同样地，有一个非常非常著名的段落，他描述了这一点，你知道的，穿托加袍、享受中央暖气等等的过程。因此他写道：人口逐渐被引入到拱廊、浴场和丰盛宴会的消沉诱惑中。毫无戒心的不列颠人将此类新鲜事物称之为文明，而实际上它们只是他们被奴役的一个特征。这本质上就是
of which calgarcus is talking it's not just the idea of you know a battlefield covered in bodies cut to pieces by roman swords it's also this idea that everything that makes the britains hardy and tough is being corroded and destroyed by what the romans are bringing in to the island and so this is why Tacitus is suspicious of empire. It's not for reasons I think that we would recognize today. So, you know, if people are opposed to imperialism, it's not because empires have brought the good life to distant reaches of the world. It's because empire is seen as being murderous in and of itself. But Tacitus is not lamenting that. You know, he's not condemning the Roman Empire for the reasons that we might. So the 40,000 killed
加尔古斯所谈论的荒蛮之地。这不仅仅是想象一个被罗马剑刃砍成碎片的尸体布满的战场，也是这样一种想法：一切让不列颠人坚韧顽强的东西，都在被罗马人带进岛屿的事物所侵蚀和摧毁。这就是为什么塔西佗对帝国抱有戒心。我认为原因并不是我们今天所能理解的那样。所以，如果人们反对帝国主义，并不是因为帝国给世界遥远的角落带来了美好生活。而是因为帝国本身就被视为具有谋杀性。但塔西佗并不是在为此哀叹。你知道的，他并不是出于我们可能会有的那些原因在谴责罗马帝国。所以，4万人死于
in Boudicca's last battle, the 10,000 killed at Mons Graupius, there may be 250,000. You know, this is the upper limit of David Mattingly's estimate of how many are killed over the 40 years that we've been covering in this series, probably an equal number enslaved. And if you think that probably the population of Britain in this period has been estimated at about 2 million, I mean, that's a quarter of people either killed or enslaved in this period. I mean, that is, to us, a terrifying record of conquest. And yet no Roman, including Tacitus, ever expresses regret for that i mean quite the opposite they celebrate it they're building massive triumphal arches about it you said that tacitus reasons for criticizing the empire are not ones we would recognize but
布狄卡最后的战役，1万人死于格鲁庇乌斯山之战，可能还有25万人——这是大卫·马廷利（David Mattingly）对我们在本系列中一直在讨论的这40年里死于战争人数的上限估计，可能还有同等数量的人被奴役。如果你考虑到这一时期不列颠的人口估计约为200万人，我的意思是，这就意味着四分之一的人在这段时期里要么被杀，要么被奴役。对我我们而言，这是一个可怕的征服记录。然而没有一个罗马人，包括塔西佗在内，曾对此表露出任何遗憾。我的意思是，恰恰相反，他们在庆祝，他们为此建造了巨大的凯旋门。你曾说塔西佗批判帝国的理由是我们所不熟悉的，但
they are ones that people would have recognized in the 18th or 19th centuries during the time of the british empire that empire, corruption, that you actually lose the very virtues that made you great by achieving greatness, that you become Warren Hastings, or you become so rich, you're no longer like a big game hunter on the veldt or something, all of that kind. That's very familiar, isn't it? It's in all empires, the fear that empire brings a kind of moral corruption because you're too rich and successful. I think that there is a definite Tacitian influence on this. Every British imperial administrator would have been familiar with the Agricola, but there's an even more sinister manifestation of this, which is that Tacitus also writes a
这些理由在18世纪或19世纪大英帝国时期的人们看来却是再熟悉不过的：帝国会导致腐化，即你在取得伟大的同时，恰恰失去了让你变得伟大的美德；你变成了沃伦·黑斯廷斯，或者你变得如此富有，以至于不再像维尔特草原上的大猎手了，诸如此类。这不是很熟悉吗？在所有帝国中都有这种担忧：由于你过于富裕和成功，帝国带来了一种道德上的腐败。我认为这其中有着明确的塔西佗式的影响。每一个英国的帝国管理者都会对《阿格里科拉传》耳熟能详，但还有一个更加阴险的表现形式，那就是塔西佗还写了一本
book about the Germans, who, of course, do not get conquered. They have held the Romans off, unlike the Britons. And in this book, Tacitus pursues the same theme, that the Germans are heroic, noble, they have resisted the sapping effects of civilization, and it's this that in the long run will enable them to overcome the Romans. And this is hugely influential on the way that the Nazis understand the patterns of history and the sapping effects of empire. So the thing that's fascinating, I think, about Roman history, or I mean, there's so much that's fascinating about Roman history, one of the sources of fascination is that it is so influential on how subsequent generations
关于日耳曼人的书，他们当然没有被征服。与不列颠人不同，他们抵挡住了罗马人。在这本书中，塔西佗延续了同样的主题：日耳曼人是英雄般的、高贵的，他们抵抗了文明的削弱作用，而正是这一点在长期来看将使他们能够战胜罗马人。这极大地影响了纳粹理解历史规律和帝国削弱作用的方式。所以，我认为罗马历史最迷人的地方在于——或者说罗马历史有太多迷人的地方，其中一个吸引人的源泉就是它对后来的世代影响深远。
in more recent European history come to see the past and therefore the future so much to think about here and actually i think let's do a bonus episode maybe next week for our restless history club members exploring these issues about roman imperialism and how it has affected the way that subsequent empires have thought about their own project because i mean you've got loads to say about that's a great idea dominic wonderful well it's actually your idea um it's actually it's a great idea i'm not. Wonderful. Well, it's actually your idea. That's right, it's a great idea. I'm not going to take any credit for it.
在近代欧洲历史中，它如何看待过去，从而如何看待未来，这里有太多值得思考的地方。实际上，我觉得我们或许可以在下周为我们的“不息历史俱乐部”成员制作一期特别节目，探讨关于罗马帝国主义的这些问题，以及它如何影响了后来的帝国看待自身宏伟计划的方式。因为，我的指是，你对这方面有太多的见解了。是个好主意，多米尼克，太棒了。好吧，其实这是你的主意。那是个好主意，我可不打算居功。
But Tom, just to finish up for our regular listeners. So this brings to an end our little series about the making of Roman Britain. So just to throw ahead, with the end of Agricola's mission and the withdrawal to what becomes the line of Hadrian's Wall, would it be fair to say, I know this is a ridiculous,
不过，汤姆，为了我们的普通听众，我们来做个收尾。这就结束了我们关于塑造罗马不列颠的小系列。那么展望未来，随着阿格里科拉使命的结束以及向哈德良长城防线方向的撤退，这样说是否公允——我知道这是一个荒谬的、
oversimplistic generalisation, that to some extent, the story is now over for the next 300 years. Of course, things happen in Britain. There are mutinies or there are uprisings or whatever. But by and large, the story is now settled until, what, the beginning of the 5th century.
过度简化的泛泛而谈——在某种程度上，在接下来的300年里，这个故事现在基本上结束了？当然，不列颠还会发生一些事情。会有兵变、会有起义之类的。但大体上，直到公元5世纪初，这个故事现在算是尘埃落定了。
Would that be fair? Well, we're very lucky that we have as many sources as we do for this period and it's evident from throwaway lines or from archaeological evidence that there are actually great convulsions continue to happen so the ninth legion for instance which has been repeatedly mauled throughout this story it vanishes and that inspires the famous story eagle of the ninth by rosemary suck cliff and there's much debate as to what actually happened to the ninthth Legion. But the fact that we don't really know what happened to it is evidence of how many gaps in the record there are. And over the course of the centuries
这样说公平吗？好吧，我们很幸运，能为这一时期保留下这么多的史料，从不经意的台词或考古证据中可以明显看出，巨大的动荡其实仍在继续。例如，在这整个故事中屡遭重创的第九军团消失了，这激发了罗斯玛丽·萨特克利夫（Rosemary Sutcliff）创作了著名的故事《第九军团之鹰》，关于第九军团究竟发生了什么，存在着很多争论。但我们其实并不知道它发生了什么这一事实，恰恰证明了史料中存在着多少空白。而在随后的漫长岁月里
that follow right the way up to the end of Roman Britain, Britain politically is very significant. It has about a tenth of the entire armed forces in the empire as a garrison. And in the long run, this means that it becomes, Saint Jerome describes it in the fourth century as the womb of tyrants, by which he means it's a place that fosters would-be Caesars who are endlessly kind of launching attempts to establish themselves as empires throughout the third and fourth centuries and actually i don't think it brings the history of roman britain to an end so maybe a story to pursue in some later later episode definitely certainly we should look at hadrian's wall definitely and of course britain plays a part in the rise of constantine the great doesn't it so he does yes yeah and helena of course comes from saint helena his mother of course comes from
直到罗马不列颠的终结，不列颠在政治上都非常重要。它作为驻军，拥有帝国全部武装力量的大约十分之一。从长远来看，这意味着它成为了——圣杰罗姆在公元四世纪将其描述为“暴君的子宫”——他的意思是，这是一个孕育蓄意称帝者的温床，他们在整个三四世纪里不断地发起建立自己帝国的尝试。实际上，我不认为这为罗马不列颠的历史画上了句号，所以这或许是一个可以在之后的某期节目中继续探讨的故事。当然，我们绝对应该研究一下哈德良长城，而且不列颠当然也在君士坦丁大帝的崛起中发挥了作用，不是吗？他确实是的。是的，海伦娜当然也来自圣海伦娜，正如每个人都知道的那样，他的母亲当然来自
essex as everyone knows and essex girl so and of course the end of Roman Britain's a great story so brilliant we'll be back in Roman Britain for our club members with a discussion about Roman imperialism and its effect on later empires but for now Tom a tour de force as always thank you very much and we'll see you all next time bye-bye Ave Equivali I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull
埃塞克斯，是个埃塞克斯女孩。当然，罗马不列颠的结局也是一个精彩的故事。太棒了，我们将在罗马不列颠与我们的俱乐部成员重聚，共同探讨罗马帝国主义及其对后来的帝国的影响。但就目前而言，汤姆，一如既往的精彩绝伦，非常感谢你，我们下期节目再见，拜拜。大家好，我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《一切皆娱乐》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、八卦猛料的专属节目。在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开
back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、额外节目以及提前获得现场门票的权限，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。